yeah welcome to this video this is a new
episode would off your games reviewed
yeah the viewer games are back hand the
never really were gone it's just that it
takes a lot of time to do this kind of
video and I didn't didn't have it
recently but yeah here we go I'm
actually going to do two games in that
video him so one viewer sent me two of
his games and he said I'll choose one
take one of the one of the two but
ultimately I decided to show both I'm
going to be a little more a bit more
thorough with the first one on going to
more detail with the first game but the
second game had so many interesting
lines that I thought yeah it should be
should be shown okay um to get more
information about this game obvious
black I have kept the names secret
he's a 1600 player and his opponent is
rated 1850 so he's a pretty clear
underdog in that game here with black
let's see what happened we have d 46 C
form check and this check here yeah that
line sometimes called the carers defense
it's relatively rare response to Bondi
for but not because it is bad I think
it's actually a pretty good opening
um this check on the second I have
played this um a bit myself over the
years I think the only reason why it is
not seen more frequently on the
Grandmaster level is the simple reason
that people have to be ready for the
French defence and not every player is
ready for that so that's the drawback of
1e6 obviously if you don't play the
French you kind of gambling but yeah
this opening in itself is quite quite
good for black I mean no not an
advantage but it's very it's very
reasonable choice 93 played here by the
opponent normal-looking move mostly
played by people who allow the names oh
yeah which we
cooking's supposed to if black now plays
Knight f6 however this doesn't really
try to make anything out of this
particular move order and black can try
to do that he has two moves to give this
position now some some distinct flavor
King go c5 or b6 our viewer here went to
see 5 b6 is also interesting move
leading to and after this for example
two lines of the English defense with a
six be 6 but c5 is good also move that
by the way I have played in tournament
chess the white player now goes for the
most a 3 which is hinting that he might
have played the same issue aviation
against the pure names oh yeah III the
same machine weathers the news there is
a line that have played quite a bit here
in bits chess but it's again it's a line
that is some fairly risky against the
pure names oh and I think actually
against the move orders shown here it is
some a little bit more than risky maybe
it's a little bit it's a little bit
shaky I think for whites to play like
that and we will see in the game why I
think this is not the most promising
line yeah what should Y do against c5
the most popular choice is on Knight to
f3 you have to be ready to recapture
with the knight or III and this is
actually what I would recommend one of
those two if you allow this in the first
place actually I believe that White's
best mushiya after the check
a 92 and Bishop d2 I think 93 is so it's
simply not the best move but it's um
yeah it's a different story of course
all of those lines let's see a3 and to
understand why I think this isn't that
great we need to draw a comparison or we
need to see the comparison to the pure
damage main line let's do that in them
pure damage this is plate he just takes
c5 and now why this building up his
center
it's not let's look at this form and in
this particular moment this is the
absolute main line of this line of the
names Oh at this moment black is faced
with a threat and this threat is Bishop
g5 for the pin move iam if black is
ignoring this and just plays any move
yeah I mean say something like this this
is going to be a problem
the threat is a five winning a piece and
black really has a hard time to get rid
of that pin yeah there is no Bishop
anymore to break the pin it has been
traded on c3 so black is in trouble here
yeah he has to play some some really
awkward stuff to get rid of the pin so
black is playing against this idea of
the pin and goes 98 this is an absolute
key move in the same issue Arian one
additional point of the move besides
just avoiding the pin is that after
let's say this is just to show the idea
after white is expanding here with his
monster Center black has to move f5
that's a very important resource if
black is not going for f5 himself white
will push a 5 for example after move
like Knight a5 what can go here it has
the idea to even push f6
yeah after Knight f6 again there's a pin
what has some attacking ideas here that
are really dangerous but f5 is the move
that tries to fix here on light squares
and keeps this Bishop bad gather c1
Bishop it's looking at the f4 pawn the
d3 Bishop is looking at the c4 pawn that
is what this is a strategically risky
opening for white
we need to kept to keep that in mind
black has played Knight you have six
years play Knight to e8 back and then he
has played at five keep that in mind
let's go back to the game c5
III takes takes yeah
now b6 was played yeah I got this game
with some short annotations by by the
player by by our viewer and I'm going to
use this annotations a little bit to
tell you what he thought and we compare
that with my thinking process I think
this is an interesting thing and also a
reason why I chose that game he dislike
to be six yeah in his annotation and
said he should have played just Knight
f6 to make sure that if is not happening
and Knight f6 is not a bad move it's
just transposes to the to the line that
we just looked at before this is the
pure Samish now out of the nihms oh no
bad at all but I don't think that b6 is
any particular problem white can play a
form but this is not something to be am
particularly afraid of it seems that he
felt that white had a chance here with
e4 to get an advantage I don't think
that this is really the case white in
the game played the move III which yeah
well it's not necessary at all he can
play you for and he should do that but I
don't think that black has a has a huge
problem here yeah after you for you will
probably play in the same vein as in the
game like let's let's say like this 97
Bishop him 96 and now I don't know
Knight f3 or 92 it's both viable let's
say this and something like Bishop a6
now or d6 we will see something very
comparable in the game but why does
tempo down in the game because he played
III and then he form
III and now 97 was played and he says
some yeah he starts to go wrong here he
wanted to play f5 and Knight f6 um this
is not really wrong
97 putting the knight on e7 is one of
the benefits of this move on actually
yeah the idea to delay the knight
development
can be very useful and now 97 does make
perfect sense the reason is that you
very often want to have the f5 push as
we had seen in the Samish mainline to
stop the white center and it's simply a
different kind of setup here but it's
the same idea in the in the Newman so
you have Knight to f6 you jump back to 8
and then you push a5 until you play just
97 in one go and then f5 so it's a
totally a comparable idea that this is
actually a little bit more yeah it's
very smooth way to to to set up your
pieces like is perfectly OK after 97
there's nothing nothing wrong with it at
all of course 90 f6 would transpose to
them to the nihms oh but 97 is a good
way to to play and I think that really
white has some issues here he now tries
to play a typical damaged style
Bishop d3 and 92 and I'm not really sure
if this is a great idea it's it's maybe
maybe already a case can be made for
yeah trying to play it like this Knight
f3 to d2 to have more protection of c4
it's not what you want it's not a dream
scenario of a white but we will see that
in the game
why does getting into into huge trouble
quite quickly 92 96 or very nice efore
and now he went Knight to a5 yeah that's
all very logical and exactly how it
should be played yeah the night comes to
a5 and the texts the week c4 pawn the c4
pawn is the problem pawn of course of
this opening it is very often lost
simply because why there's a hard time
to defend it against this combined
attack of Knight to a5 and Bishop on a6
however white quite often get some some
dynamic compensation for the point this
is not happening in the game
so I think this is really a clearly
clearly inferior version of the famous
variation especially considering that
why he has lost his temper with first
III and then he fought and he went III
first and then only then pushed reform
he went to Bishop III now what player
did and our you viewer played to move d6
yeah
d6 is perfectly fine of course he was
varied that maybe white will take the
pawn on c5 an idea to remember whatever
is that like it's not really obliged to
cover that pawn in all cases here also
Bishop a6 came into consideration which
basically trades the c5 pawn for the c4
pawn yeah after the capture Knight c4
for example is definitely a very decent
position for for black yeah for example
if white takes it here we have a very
nice bishop there on c4 nicely placed
and after something like this White's
pawn structure here and the LightSquared
weaknesses are really problematic
Black has a pretty pretty good position
here his weaknesses are far less
important or or easy to attack so Bishop
e3 Bishop a6 was an alternative d6 oh
it's however not bad though of your
plate he just supported his c5 pawn yeah
white now went f4 you know f4 the kind
of the typical way how the same is
variation is sometimes played just push
the whole center forward oh I think it's
a mistake but okay let's let's go to
that date I think what probably has to
it has to go with 93 to have Queen e2 as
a as an additional support of the c4
pawn so after this he can go Queen e2 I
mean black is very comfortable in this
Lucian but yeah it's what white simply
needs to do there's not much else okay
you went there for and now I have USS
I've lost the center never played f5 I'm
instead obsessed with winning the double
pawn which may not be worth winning so
early um well if you can win their pawn
on c4 and you're not getting checkmated
you should simply take it because it is
the weakness and if you can take it well
go ahead in this position black cam went
Queen d7 but if he goes Bishop e6 now
which is very logical yeah it's a
logical continuation of Black's play I
simply don't see how white keeps a
playable position here I think cam Oh No
yeah I mean on some level white is
busted here
yeah c4 gets lost I don't see me does he
cannot keep it it's just a lost pawn and
and the problem is quite often if the
pong gets lost your compensation that
white might get has to be there quickly
really quickly the issue is that c4 is
not just a pawn getting lost but also
your light squares are terribly weakened
if you imagine a scenario let's say
white castles I mean he just loses the
pawn he has no way to keep it so castles
if you ask Queen a for trying to keep it
that's just Queen e8 and that's it
yeah Queens Queens are traded and then
c4 drops next and there's not even any
kind of activity here simply with Queens
off this is basically winning for black
you win a pawn and you have structure
yeah let's let's have a look at Bishop
a6 castle this is probably the most
likely move that white would play but
Bishop c4 now yeah and the thing that
what I mentioned about the light squares
is just one possible scenario if you
imagine white takes which is not not
even good but just this look how strong
this Knight is
yeah just a fantastic piece it can be
easily supported by D 5 or B 5 and it's
just sitting in White's Campins very
very annoying to face in many cases you
can also support with d5 yeah let's just
say not Queen d3m takes takes d5 just
yeah something like that I went Knight
f5 that's wrong wrong arrow when Knight
f5 might come does this kind of thing is
just excellent for black and there may
be ways to improve but I just want to
show the general idea it's just not a
pawn going down on c4 but with it almost
the whole position if white keeps the
bishop on black has this idea which
shows how nicely placed this is actually
f5 is just a very strong move even white
cheeks we will capture and the knight is
just very strong and also note that d5
can be a possible stronghold for blacks
bishop or Knight after regrouping and
like Knight here here here so a very
nice position and well this is a very
stupid looking Bishop so with Bishop a6
um blacks position would have been
really overwhelming to me it's a little
bit mysterious why that move was not
played because it clearly belongs to
Black's agenda he played Queen d7 by the
way which is some not really essential
the Queen very often goes to the 7 in
this kind of position to have a little
bit of additional support for the f5
move so it's not a wrong move in terms
of yeah what belongs into the position
in terms of patterns and and things like
that but it's just not the best one
Bishop a6 wins the pawn on c4 and with
it probably the game and this is an
opportunity that should be taken if you
can play Bishop a6 you should do that
and take the pawn the thing is it's
clear that we want to attack c4 and
possibly win it and it's not so clear if
we want the Queen on d7 in all cases so
ship has to go to a six simply because
there's never any other place that it's
going to go Bishop a six just belongs
into that position and you definitely
want to take the pawn so Queen d7 was
played and white player now went with
castles yeah okay by the way Queen d7
keeps a black advantage it's just not as
good as Bishop a six push up a six yeah
White Castle it's not clear he has
anything better but now Bishop a six was
played and now Knight G 3 after Knight G
3 and again black black has a fantastic
position he white head I think white
what was very I don't know very
laid-back here about us about this thing
I think after 93 is basically losing the
game but I think he should have tried
something drastic to try to muddy the
waters I mean f5 suggested itself just
to get something going I think this is
what white really had to do even though
it's not objectively speaking really
great fun but Knight G 3 just gives up
the game without a fight yeah he takes
everything black should take it takes
yeah now an interesting moment like now
has a choice he can play f6 just
stopping the F pawn from going any
further which however we can see six a
little bit denied f4 could prove tricky
I mean I don't think that White has
enough here but at least it's it's kind
of its kind of murky yeah the night
might come to you 6 on a good tape or
black can play differently you can also
just take it and say okay I don't mind
f6 95 is a good move takes rook e8 and
again this seems to be good for black
but it is reasonably here this is
nothing it seems good for black but it's
reasonably murky at least it looks like
a fight in the game
blacks advantage has decisive
proportions and white doesn't even have
any counter play so he went 93 the white
played it and black now took the pawn of
course that is the whole purpose of
96-95 and Bishop a6 yeah and right now
absolutely surprisingly took on c5 again
I thought f5 yeah trying to stir up some
trouble he took on c5
yeah and now this next move from or the
next sequence of moves is quite
mysterious and it's also not something
that our viewer here mentions in his
annotations he now took on d3 with the
bishop and yeah this is mysterious
because if we if we check what happens
first of all Queen takes pawn takes e5
Bishop c5 Knight b3 a rather complicated
line yeah we were seeing them in the
analysis later that this is complicated
and not at all clear however if you are
in this position and you are black you
have to look at well three candidate
moves yeah if we think of candidate
moves
taking on d3 taking on c5 with the
b-pawn
taking on c5 with the D pawn and we
should check all three moves once we get
to the point that we check D takes e5 we
see that the D follow is opened and it's
a double attack ever backed by Queen and
Bishop on d3 so there's pressure on this
Bishop and White has to react to that
this line gets forced it's a forcing
forcing line now because white right now
basically only has one move the only
move here to e to continue the game as
Bishop c2 if you take on c4 for example
after the Queen trade and Knight takes
on Z for blacks advantage is
overwhelming and something like that we
have one upon we have a fantastic piece
on c4 this
night is just so great it's in front of
this pawn it's not in any way attackable
by a white piece even and it looks at
the 8th reborn in addition yeah this is
a pawn up and the strategically winning
position for black so it is relatively
speaking better to play Bishop c2 using
the fact that after Queen d1 the f1 rook
can recapture so white is not losing the
exchange
however after Bishop c2 we can conclude
that after something like this white is
forced to trade and once we reach this
position in our calculation we can
basically discard everything else
because here black is a pawn up he has
traded Queens which means is not going
to get checkmated on the King side which
is basically the only thing left for
white is a situation with porn down and
rotten structure basically commits them
to checkmate or die in the endgame that
same and here we are close to the
endgame it is it is almost an endgame
Queens are traded and well pawn up good
structure Queens traded many weaknesses
yeah look at this
it's all week it's all weekend this is a
fantastic situation for black with D
takes e5 yeah with D takes d5 we forced
the Queen trade and we force in many
situations the trade of light squared
bishop which also is very favorable for
black so this is a mysterious moment in
this game D takes e5 would have led to
yeah this is a winning position for
black really and it hints maybe at them
yeah at a weakness in our viewers played
the scene that he did not make a
thorough check of all the possible moves
here I understand that after what he
played if we look at what he played he
took took with the be pawn white
captures and 93 this is a tempting line
well made so it's
double attack but the other position is
just clearly clearly better and once you
come to this situation with Queen takes
d6 once you come to this in your
calculation you will see that it is it's
getting complicated now yeah after Queen
t6 Bishop d6 there's East 7 hanging what
about the night on a1 will it come come
out of whites camp here black is an
exchange up for a pawn in some lines
nice but in the other nine Queens traded
winning structure got an extra pawn this
is just better it's just better without
any counter plan without anything that
is kind of weak and unclear yeah and
here yeah it's not easy it's not so easy
to play that they got exactly this
position and now it was some our viewers
choice to play and he played Knight
takes e5 this is yet another somewhat
mysterious move if you are that far you
have to go for Queen d6 and take the
rook after 95 Queen c5 yeah white is a
pawn up and to be honest Black has
compensation really yeah like has
compensation for that pawn but it is
simply not going for the maximum if you
think about this Queen d6 Bishop d6 it's
a force line
night-night grabs rook White has to take
on his 7 otherwise I mean this is kind
of and 96 next this is just just an
exchange for a pawn so this is this
Bishop e7 Ruby 8 Bishop d6 and the night
comes back so the knight is not trapped
and black is there with an exchange up I
mean you have to do that there's really
no way around this round this this is
being material up and White's
compensation is not clear
in the other situation we are porn down
for some compensation so this is clearly
am the the more yeah the more principled
way to play by the way I think maybe
Luke takes anyone is indeed strong and
now that I look at it my notes don't
mention that but this is probably
stronger in comparison to the other
thing yeah this this and then maybe see
five coming we white discontinued here
is not like lost but this is what black
has to do you have to take the material
and say okay show me yeah this is the
the better approach then well sitting
there with a pawn down and hoping for
compensation like here black has some
compensation and this is due to the fact
that whites a yeah not great pawn
structure with the split pawn cm always
gives black some play we will see it in
the game they went back group c1 and
Queen b6 this is what he played and it's
interesting to read the notes he says
I'm obviously suffering not just down
material but with a weak back rank and
the night that is not well placed I have
a couple of points to take though and
I'm trying to do so
yeah well the black is not really
suffering that much I mean he had much
much better alternatives along the way
but this is a position where I know I
wouldn't be well I would be concerned
but I wouldn't be in in panic mode
because in many cases black will have
from ideas really against the pawns and
in
in a lot of in a lot of situations you
will get the pawn back and when you get
the pawn back in fact quite often black
would even be better so I wouldn't be so
concerned he I think he was a little bit
too panicky him um black for example a
simple solution here for black would be
something like Knight to c6 yeah he
mentioned that his knight only 7 is not
well placed so well go ahead put it to
c4 why not 96 is a good good way to
start
for example Queen back and then no
Knight a5 94 this is a good square for
the knight so let's let's go there white
of course has display mp5 94 94 this is
a possible variation but this is not at
all clear I mean the c3 pawn is why it's
extra pawn and to be honest it doesn't
look like it's going to promote anytime
soon and as long that is not happening
it's not such a big deal note that also
well a3 is not not a strong strong point
White's Kemp either so this is not clear
and by the way this type of position is
very well known in the name zone with
the extra pawn why does not
automatically winning due to his
LightSquared weaknesses so this is not
so bad I think one problem here was that
our viewer yeah was was panicking a
little bit and thinking okay well I'm
really really bad shape and this is not
the case really this position is um well
I wouldn't start to celebrate yeah but
it's it gives you very very decent
chances to to hold it with good good
defensive skills
yeah Queen b6 is not really helping in
that regard
King h1 yeah note that the Queen trade
is of course very helpful for black so
that was probably the idea but white is
not going to take you played King as one
that's a good move
would be eight Queen here and night went
to g6 yeah again 96 was an idea yeah the
night g6 move it's not it's not so
obvious to me what the Knight is doing
on on g6 yeah I mean okay you attack f4
too but I think c4 looks like a very
decent square for the for the night so
we should aim for that yeah maybe it
wasn't so clear to the black player
where he ultimately wanted the knight to
have if he really am yeah made up his
mind that okay I want to go to c4 that's
the square I want to go to then knight
c6 is kind of yeah suggesting itself
night g6 was played d5 and queen e3
trying for for counter play there
against f4 yeah okay white went Queenie
for Queen d2 and now white pushed f5
this is the debatable move really f5
it's it's active it's very active but it
is also um yeah a bit tricky in terms of
pawn structure the e5 pawn gets weak
after that if you play a five you really
have to need to have a very concrete
idea of how to continue after the
capture white however now talked with
the Queen and I think this is not really
a leading to that much Knight f5 that
was an idea to make f5 yeah to give f5
some more bite
the idea here can be to put the Queen on
g4 and possibly push the APH part of the
bot just going for for an attack in any
case it was a very responsible decision
to play a five and E 5 is just weak
yeah and what our view SS um where is it
he mentioned them White's
rotten yeah crisp with three split pawns
there should be some some fight in the
position
that's true that's really true it's very
important to note that white has very
much split pawns in the game with Queen
f5 Knight f5 was much better it is even
that debatable if white has an advantage
Queen d7 Queenie 4 doesn't want to trade
and Queen d5 that's that's totally fine
note how weak the e5 pawn is rook e1 was
played rook c8 also good using this is
rook and white now played h3 okay
probably he was worried about his back
rank Queens were traded and now the move
rook e8 ya notice one weakness to
bigness three weaknesses and black only
has the a7 pawn as a potential targets
for White's pieces the knight on G also
is not very well placed in this position
black is totally fine that was the
result after of this f5 push to connect
it with Queen takes f5 black here is
fine so how did it continue after rook
e8 white went Knight to f5 we are
wanting to active or activate the knight
pawn was taken why not
the important trick is that after the
movement 96 which was not played Black
has 93 and he's okay due to that
counter-attack against the rook
by the way black also had this myth just
waiting a moment and threatening rook c5
they're a rookie five I'm sorry that was
also very much ok for him but it's a
good move 95 is no problem at all
rook e1 was played and yeah this is now
in a very important and decisive moment
of the game um
yeah after rook e1 the knight on d5 is
quite obviously pinned yeah we cannot
move the knight as the eight is falling
so black really wants to play the move
f6 making sure that the knight is safely
protected as it is a tech term in the
first place
however after f6 there is 96 this big
Fork
so if you start to calculate yeah you
have to determine the candidate most and
there are really only two f6 covering a5
I mean you don't want to give up the
night or rook c5 keeping the knight
protected after f6 there's 96 after rook
c5 there is no fork so you have to play
walk c5 just keep the night however he
went f6 yeah and then 96 just hit so
this can only be a case of I know sloppy
calculation or or blundering in this
particular case it is a totally concrete
position just decided by move by most
calculation if I was hanging you have to
keep the night there are only two moves
one one just secure the night and keep
keeps black in the game there are other
drops in exchange and you simply have to
play rook c5 that's it and in fact um
white now can force a draw yeah you can
basically force a draw with them with
them attacking attacking
nine p7 maybe even yeah rookie seven is
also possible with this kind of this
kind of perpetual thing but well here if
anybody does have something it's black
because if you get to play f6 and repeat
to c7 I like here yeah keeping the night
switching over taking c3 then black is
clearly in command but okay white has
various ways with his active pieces to
to force some kind of repetition or
meaning is he is active enough to draw
but this has to be played after f6
that's just 96 and that's it just it's
just the exchange and black really has
no particular chancy to hold it his
Knight is at the moment quite strong on
e5 but ultimately it is really just a
complete exchange and whites rooks I
active and white display at define yeah
he pushes the C pawn and yeah he kind of
offers this offer this pawn but the
issue is that yeah ultimately the a pawn
will get lost so this is not yeah not
helpful for black at all it eases
White's task King f7 was played rooks e1
yeah c5 again yeah here he offered the
pawn for sake of trading this would be a
fairly simple endgame wind with white
coming to c7 so good technical player by
white yeah rook will enter and now f6 is
falling so after that black gets
basically lost yes I don't want to go
into this much further
like what's riding on but it wasn't lost
and why this wide return the exchange
for being two pawns up but this is a
winning endgame so it's not yeah not
really really am leading too much to
look at it in much detail I rather want
to look at the second game a little bit
so what is the essence of this game
let's go back and look at a couple of
key points black played this slightly
unconventional nimzo-indian type of
opening but it seems that at least if
you look at the the annotation that he
wasn't aware how good his setup is
actually yeah that this Knight is seven
is in fact one of the ideas of a setup
so he played it with the autumn really
being aware of some benefits of his
particular move on the key moment is is
here where Bishop a6 was stronger than
27 but even with that it was a very
strong position as why did not really
yeah even try it to get any kind of
counter play after this and the capture
on c5 here we have the moment I think of
the game as details c5 is is basically
winning black has a huge advantage after
that and he will get Queens traded and
will play a farm one let's say I'm yeah
this position is far easier to play in
Harrison to to anything else simply
because there is little tactics it's
very it's very stable and tidied up
let's aim yeah after this month after
that here it gets yeah it gets very
messy by the way by the way it's
important to mention I forgot that
actually the bishop takes the five
movies of course a mistake and that
gives us gives black the advantage with
93 rook ad one was much better attacking
this first and keeping this Bishop c5
option open so that after this then we
can take which is much better because
this is no no [ __ ] F walk anymore so
this is what white should have done
actually I'm sorry about that I should
have mentioned that in the original
commentary yeah this is a mistake due to
now b3 and now black had to grab the
exchange and not play this position a
pawn down it wasn't terrible the
position of porn down but well you can
take the exchange you should do that
yeah and let the other guy show what his
compensation is it wasn't it wasn't the
full compensation really okay let's have
a look at the second game just a moment
yeah second game is loaded and again
it's served from blacks point of view
our viewer has the black pieces yeah the
same person as in Game one and he's
playing a much higher rated opponent
1914 is the other guy's rating so we got
one be three played yeah rambles but has
gained some popularity recently um our
viewer played 86 which is not bad but to
be honest I really think that if white
is not taking in the center we should so
ii v d5 one of the most if v is the best
move it's really the best move I think
in comparison and just grab as much of
the center as you can not that he 6 is a
mistake but why limit yourself to small
moves if you can play e5 so
I would really advise to do that even
even if you're not a 1d 4 player it
makes perfect sense to play e5 or if not
just go d5 and keep this option open to
get your Bishop out okay well it's not a
mistake it's just it feels like black is
limiting itself a little bit f4 yeah
white is going for this Dutch type of
setup you should be 793 castles u3 + b6
yeah that's okay
if you played like that fianchetto and
on the queenside this make lots of sense
so Bishop b2 yeah I think the next move
is it's not annotated by our view here
but I think it's it's a mistaken idea
he went to Bishop a6 looking for a trade
down of the bishop I think this is
actually a mistake and the reason is
that this is a welcome treat for white
one thing to ask him is if you play
Bishop b7 let's say castle and you play
something like c5 put upon there let us
have a look at what is White's plan in
this position it's not so easy to say
actually one reason is that if we are
not going to play d5 as black the move
Knight e5 doesn't make much sense as d6
is kicking in the night back white
really have some problems here with
giving us play some kind of bite for
example if you try to gain space with d3
here
you're really weakened just your square
and pawn they're only three quite a bit
and let's say after this black is just
like only for a ton of times really a
ton of times and d4 is difficult to play
if we compare that to the game note also
that the bishop is not a particularly
great piece in the game after let's say
we should be six White Castle LT took
note that it also takes time white got
the Queen to e2 and he's glad about that
Trey because now d3 e4 looks
relatively simpler to simple as simple
to accomplish quite often white wants to
trade this e to Bishop and uses Tempe
for that in the opening like Bishop b5
check if the D pawn moves early and
taking on d7 yeah black has invested two
moves to get a trade and that is not
necessarily helping him as the bishop on
b7 would have been a much stronger piece
yeah look at this long diagonal then the
bishop only two so you trade a piece
which is essentially better than the
other guys piece and yeah this is this
is not a good deal
Queeny - yeah now black went d5
this move is certainly aimed at
controlling the e4 square but something
that you have to be aware of if you go
d5 in this position and it was not
necessary yet yeah black had
alternatives to play without the move
like c5 for example it was perfectly
playable if you go d5 in this position
you really have to think about one thing
the long diagonal yeah this is a long
diagonal and d5 is weakening this
staying a little bit yeah for example
the square e 5 is much more of an
outpost now if you play d5 you really
should keep in mind that okay I have to
fight on the slow negra I cannot just
give him this diagonal as a yeah as a
starting point for active operations
against my king this is very important
the long Langer he is aiming towards
blacks King and after d3 the next move
his is interesting
he played rook to e8 kind of a
mysterious move I first thought that it
could have been the start of a averred
of a decent plan but it's not follow it
follow followed up upon it's just that
the move seems disconnected with with
the next it doesn't connect with the
next couple of moves
I actually thought blacks idea might
have been ok white played
pd2 we can put that on the board that's
expected I thought black played rookie
aid to maybe play this Bishop f8 g6
Bishop g7 this is a slow plan and I'm
not sure I would recommend it but it
kind of fits with rookie aid in some way
he didn't do that he played the move c6
and this is a move that clearly shows
that black is not at this particular
moment it's not aware of the dangers he
absolutely should think about what is
the setup that makes me fight for this
diagonal for this squares and the first
move of that can only be c5 you have to
go c5 and 96
this is the best square for the knight
it does support a couple of things for
example it supports d5 to d4 trying to
make this bishop look stupid just to
show that idea okay White's moves are
not great but let's just show the idea
like this this I'd say and something
like here you have this idea
go d4 and try to blunt this Bishop may
make it look try to make it look a
little bit stupid on b2 this is one idea
and also if you put this knight on c6
you have Knight F to d7 and possibly
Bishop f6 fighting for this diagonal
maybe trying to trade off the dark
squared bishop this is absolutely mean
note that it doesn't really connect to
rupee eight but so you have to do
something active now
he went c6 however and o95 is coming and
again you have to fight this now and he
doesn't he plays Queen c7 9b d7 what
about this move yeah this is also an
idea trying to trade here quickly or get
in f6 yeah let's say like here you can
think of this move yeah okay White has
no g4 and it might be dangerous but at
least the diagonal is blunted and 95 is
not coming so quickly again so you have
to fight against the opponent's main
idea if you let him do his things and
don't get get any counter play
this is really a good idea and we see
that black is losing tons of time yeah
Queen c7 Knight bt7
rook t1 it's kind of mysterious hook t1
don't don't quite sure what this does
but look at the 8 is also not played
with a particular pen particular plan
King edge 1 and now roogie have 8 this
is actually a good move
yeah the idea is to maybe play Knight to
e8 and then f6 a really good move for
defensive purposes if you go Bishop d6
White has Queen g3 so this does not help
like it's not in a position to really
win the fight for that Square anymore
okay rook f8 and Queen Anne Age 3 was
played yeah so again black has to get
counter play he has to make up his mind
how is he getting rid of the night how
is he fighting against this pressure on
the long diagonal and it simply doesn't
place Bishop d6 now if you play this for
example you're in much better shape the
idea is to take on e5 and possibly play
f6 at the right moment it also protects
g7 for example just a sample line if
white goes here you go c5 and now no no
how does white continue it's not that
easy actually
yeah if white trades we are basically
happy that helps us Knight g5 takes and
if I was hanging so what would have to
yeah do some trades and well here we are
in decent enough shape so 98 and c5 what
else white can try to play like this you
know use the pawn to check but then
black gets this f6 idea yeah and
something like G form f6 Knight takes
Queen takes
and then possibly 96 is kind of okay for
black I'd rather be white but it's
playable you can fight this and you're
not getting chicken made on g7 so
quickly Bishop d6 Iowa was played and I
D 2 F 3 and now Bishop c5 but this is
not helping at all but by now black is I
think maybe too much too much too much
problems if you go 98 now for example if
you try to pick up on on that area
Knight g5 is going to be very strong
yeah just mating here and if black is
playing h6 what is going to smash on f7
it's really a huge problem group chicks
night eggs yeah it's very strong or I'll
turn to read this and this is also very
strong threatening Knight takes Queen
cakes and mate yeah and that's it
basically like it's getting killed him
yeah White's attack is by now too strong
he's got everything everything on the
King and I don't think you can still get
a good playable position here Bishop c5
was played Rudy you won that isn't even
the best move 97 was a bit stronger but
ok 97 queen g4 this kind of idea was
even stronger okay Bishop before a black
it's not really helping him with his
moves and B 595 yeah we see there the
tech gets very very strong age six was
played and here the white player um yeah
just just commits a mistake it's it's a
bit it's a bit strange though here white
could have won the game immediately by
taking one of seven and
I'm not quite sure what he what he
missed them because it's a fairly
straightforward affair Knight f7 Roopa
takes Knight takes King takes that's
totally forced and now the next move g4
is also yeah not really rocket science
you tried to play g5 and pry the whole
thing open black really is just getting
getting killed yeah yeah like hearin g5
back before and f5 coming in well this
is a disaster and white it's not even
material down yeah he doesn't have he
does not have he didn't need to
sacrifice anything else that's important
yeah instead he went back and this is
giving black a little bit a little bit
of relief I mean okay age for age six
has weakened for G 45 but the other
thing was winning immediately still it's
not fun yeah
black played c5 now I'm I don't know
yeah you have other moves maybe you
should take here only five and then
continue from there after Bishop takes
and G forever
it is very dangerous Jim Bishop e7 maybe
yeah those those kind of moves they put
up more resistance but blacks position
is not something - yeah - enjoy c5 g4 is
strong all right
h7 and rubgy - yeah rook g2 is keeping
in a big advantage but g5 already was
was leading to a devastating attack and
yeah probably to a quick win a very very
CUTE line to look at is for example this
takes takes takes
Bishop takes Queen somewhere Mooji - and
at the end this is quite neat yeah Queen
g7 maid and this is also not not ending
particularly well okay rook G 2 was
played its the slower way to do it but
still very strong f6 and 96 yeah instead
of 96 White had a more powerful move g5
but he didn't play that this would have
been a bit more forceful even for
example like this check and this and
black is getting getting wiped out very
very quickly
yeah something like this is already
threatening mate he went here however
which it's not spoiling anything it's
just not not so forceful g5 it's a good
move H takes g5 and now yeah now
something something curious happens
white plays the move Queen takes is 6
and this all of a sudden gives black
some chances to to consolidate after F
takes G 5 White is white is simply
winning the game and even quickly it's
not going to last very long there are
some very cute lines if black and for
example to take this here White has a
really cool sequence Jeff whoop queen
sec check check isn't this a nice
position he threatening rook g7 mate
yeah like it's black it's totally lost
yeah let's say e 5 check here for route
83 mate yeah and the best that black can
do is something like the shack
check check mate and mate very nice yeah
this would have one very crudely FK h g5
but why took only six and this all of a
sudden gives black some hope again this
is right of course yet trading the g6
night and over the tempo back takes
antiques we still of course can see that
white has an attack night h4 Knight f5
and so on but it's not like mate it's
not made immediately however it's
probably still not possible to defend
probably not
ok d4 was played blocking the long
diagonal and no no rook FG 1
yeah Luke G 1 9 th floor were stronger
getting to f5 quicker probably this wins
quite convincingly look G 111 is not as
good because now instead of Quincy 8
there was roughly 5 and this was a
potential try the defense I mean yeah
still going to be very dangerous but it
was a better try that idea said after 9h
427 f5 e 7 black is continuing to hold
and maybe can yeah can initiate some
trades like that this was played in the
game and f5 and now Ruby 7 who p7 is a
mistake which was not exploited however
it's difficult to give like any advice
once the check is so strong after rookie
7 white had a funny and quick win with
Queen g7 however he did not play that
yeah check this check
check-check
yeah jack dropped one check check mate
hey mate yeah it's made in like eight
moves but it's relatively
straightforward so certainly suddenly
calc doable yeah this this kind of
calculation why didn't do that or have
any playing Bishop sorry played Queen h5
I'm sorry
after only after here he played Bishop
c1 yeah the most rook t5 was a much
better defense again trying to defend
him by counter attacking f5 after here
d5 white does not have 96 because after
this this there is a hanging pawn so
there were a couple of defensive
alternatives but by now black certainly
also was a time travel both games were
by the way played with where is it
30 minute 30 minute per game and in a
smallish increment so it was probably a
matter of of time as well yeah in the
game here and the attack becomes becomes
unstoppable Bishop age 6 yeah and why
this breaking through on g7 it continued
a couple times but Jack White was now
picking up and picking out pieces let's
say and he overstepped the time now I
know he no he actually resigned no I'm
sorry
they drew key to seeing that shot if I
was coming and then resigned yeah so
this is the loss mostly due to the yeah
the the lack of or let's say simply not
trying to fight against the main idea
which is using the diagonal using the e5
square if black starts early to to
combat that idea it won't be that day
yeah important is that this is all
connected to the d5 move if you don't
play d5 you don't really give him the e5
square black for example could have
played I mean just for argument's sake
you could have played something like
that if you want to avoid something
coming to Judea just play in a Sicilian
style and maybe go Knight d7 and Bishop
f6 in the next next couple of moves
important is always try to be aware what
the opponent's main idea is if you fight
the main ideas very often the the worst
the and the worst is over it's the wrong
expression but nothing very serious is
going to happen to you if the main ideas
are not working as to resort to some
other ideas which are probably not that
dangerous
so here fighting on the long diagonal
trying to the post that B to Bishop and
trying to get rid of the piece on e5
would have been a good recipe quite
often this 98 move was a key idea to
defend okay that was a long video but it
had two interesting games to look at I
hope you enjoyed that thanks for
watching